les amis aujourd'hui nous allons parler
d'une histoire sacrément sympathique je
viens de me lever c'est vous dire à quel
point elle est sympathique j'ai très
bien le coup il ya sept mois j'ai envie
que j'ai envie d'être debout
je part en couilles il ya sept mois sur
twitter un utilisateur a fait le buzz
avec un thread qui comporte à l'heure
actuelle plus de 400 tweets
oui laissez moi vous donner son nom adam
est lisse tout a commencé le 7 août
dernier lorsque adam malysz je vais
m'asseoir à publier le tweet suivant
bon mon appartement est actuellement
hanté par le fantôme d'un enfant mort et
il essaye de me tuer je vais tomber
toutes les vidéos comme ça ce plan est
génial à ce moment précis le cerveau des
humains qui ont lu ce tweet a fait un
looping dans la boîte crânienne pour de
vrai un exactement comme ça parce que le
paranormal c'est un truc passionnant on
y croit on n'y croit pas mais on a tous
envie d'y croire quand même le même jour
et publie un deuxième tweet qui dit il a
commencé à apparaître dans mes rêves
mais je pense qui est maintenant passé
dans le monde réel
ça commence si bien en dessous de tout
le monde veut savoir la suite c'est
incroyable gagner trop fort il nous dit
que la première fois qu'il a vu cet
enfant c'était lors d'une paralysie du
sommeil ce genre de trucs on peut avoir
la nuit et qui fait bien bas des comme
les terreurs nocturnes aussi c'est
terrifiant c'est horrible il était en
parisis du sommeil et il a vu un enfant
assis dans la chaise qui se trouvait au
pied de son lit quoi de mieux pour
commencer à vivre un enfer que cette
situation je ne sais pas ri dessine des
dvd se garder ce trafiquant publie
d'ailleurs des pluies des pages sur
instagram et nous donne ensuite une info
importante sur physique de cette enfant
à savoir et lui manquer une partie du
crâne d'une grosse des formations d'un
côté du crâne pour notre plus grand
plaisir du coup on a pu voir aux
moindres détails la tête de cet enfant
ignoble l'enfant le fixe et lorsque d'un
coup c
levée et il s'est rapproché du bord du
lit et juste avant qu'il n'atteigne le
bord du lit notre ami adam s'est
réveillé en hurlant ces grands morts et
on aurait fait la même alors le juge ait
pas ok quelques nus plus tard adam
refait un rêve dans lequel il est dans
une librairie et une fille qui le dit y
est vous avez rencontré dire david ce à
quoi il répond qui ça il est mort il
apparaît seulement et minuit et vous
pouvez lui poser deux questions si vous
commencez par dire david qui veut dire
cher david mais n'osaient jamais lui
poser une troisième question où ils vous
tuera alors là on connais bien le coup
de minuit et nanya dame blanche d'un
blanche d'un blanche sachez-le toute
l'histoire qui commence par à minuit
pile sont fausses elles sont toutes
fausses j'ai fait moi dame blanche ok
j'étais en sueur mon pyjama mais que
j'ai fait me pisser dessus s'est rien
passé après peut-être mon charisme
imposant a fait fuir dame blanche
faut dire ce qui est bon là notre cher
adam nous dit que il se chie dessus
qu'avoir de rêve qui part de la même
chose effectivement c'est assez flippant
c'est sûrement arrivé déjà pas mal dans
le genre d'entre vous quant à des
cauchemars qui sont reliés les uns aux
autres qui se suivent alors que c'est
pas la même nuit ça fait vraiment
flipper parce qu'on a raison que c'est
très réel elodie ensuite que plusieurs
semaines sont passées sont qui les
nouvelles de david hauss e pas plus
malins vu sa gueule se désole personne
n'a envie de revoir cette personne bon
jusqu'à un jour où david apparaît de
nouveau dans un rêve de had dans la même
situation le [ __ ] david est assis dans
la chaise au pied de son lit et il fixe
adam je sais qu'il ya plein de gens qui
font ce genre de rêve mais moi j'ai des
potes qui ont déjà fait ce genre de rêve
où il y a un truc au bout leur liquide
fx et moi même quand j'étais petit j'ai
fait ce genre de rêve donc rien
d'alarmant pour le moment c'est alors
qu'adam se souvient de ce que la fille
la librairie lui avait dit et il lui
demande alors dire david comment es-tu
mort david répond alors un accident dans
un magasin qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans le magasin quelqu'un pousser une
étagère sur ma tête
moi je la vente une voie où adam se chie
dessus dans son lit et lui demande qui a
poussé l'étagère adaptés comme quoi à
lattes a dit la veuve la librairie 2 bat
troyes et n'impose 3 et les cons david
ne répond pas adam réaliste qui venait
de lui poser une troisième question ce
qui n'était pas censé faire il se
réveille alors complètement terrorisé
est franchement aux normes qui croise
l'histoire c'est génial à partir de là
adam il un bon réflexe il veut savoir
c'est la réalité au pastis thouars donc
il va enquêter sur google il va chercher
des trucs à propos d'un enfant qui
serait mort dans un accident dans un
magasin et adam des ménages dans
l'appartement qui est juste au dessus du
sien parce qu'il est plus grand que le
sien et la personne dedans donc il se
dit [ __ ] de bombe ouf givet à partir
de là il ya deux mois qui passe sans
aucune nouvelle de notre très cher david
et son morceau de crâne en moins donc
adam se dit qu'en fait en déménageant
david il n'a pas réussi à retrouver à
dam
alors fallait juste qu'ils regardent à
l'étagé au dessus ça me paraît bizarre
quand même à mais c'est parce qu'il
manque un morceau de crâne
il est moins
malin du grand pardon excusez moi
excusez moi je ne nie que le suspense
mais j'adore faire des blagues pour
désamorcer puisqu'au fond là j'ai eu
très peur j'ai pas envie de voir david
dans mes rêves cette nuit vraiment et là
il se passe un truc bizarre pendant
quatre nuits d'affilée les deux chars de
adam se met devant sa porte d'entrée et
regarde quelque chose en dessous comme
s'il y avait quelqu'un de l'autre côté
il est gentil de partage même une petite
vidéo de cette situation qui est un peu
gros quand même il est donc quasi sûr
que david a réussi à le retrouver leur a
fallu des mois pour juste montée des
marches david quand même fait un effort
et à partir de là à dame ne donne plus
de nouvelles pendant 48 heures ben oui
on continue à dame n'ayant pas le
courage d'ouvrir la porte
il a raison moi j'appelle la police
immédiatement adam décide de prendre
deux photos l'une à travers le regard de
l'apport et l'autre après avoir ouvert
la porte et en regardant ces deux photos
il a l'impression de voir sur scène à
travers le hier quelque chose
effectivement adam il y a un peu de
poussière sur ton et hier tu devrais la
nettoyer légèrement à partir de là adam
ir verrouille sa porte à bâle
il saute dans son lit se chie dessus il
a raison et publie une photo de son chat
qui attend toujours devant cette porte
d'entrée et j'avoue qu'à sa place
j'aurais peur en plus et des animaux
vous savez tout ce qu'ont déjà là vous
avec des fois non celle fondée face
bizarre et on se dit mais il voit des
choses que nous on ne voit pas s'imagine
là quand il fait ça touche à ces
horribles et c'est là où ça devient
glauque je trouve c'est que adam il
commence à s'habituer à ça et il publie
régulièrement des photos de ses chats
qui sont dans sa porte d'entrée et ça
arrive tout le temps vers le milieu de
la nuit il publie une autre vidéo il dit
voilà comme d'hab
quelques minutes avant minuit comme à
chaque fois genre ça devient normal quoi
les objets pourraient bouger freewest
normale en fantôme et c la hausse est
bien flippant séquence qui n'est pas
normal devient normal pour le mec parce
qu'ils seront plus compte du truc là
adam fait alors un move désespéré il met
du [ __ ] de celle de fin sa porte
d'entrée en mode s'éloigne les mauvais
esprits
quelques jours plus tard à dominer une
très bonne idée il télécharge une
application qui des cas du son ca
enregistre voilà je peux pas mieux
l'expliquer le matin il se lève et voit
que dans l'application il ya trente
trois enregistrements ce qui veut dire
que dans la nuit il ya eu 33 fois du
bruit chez lui et nous dit que la
plupart d'entre eux sont vagues en a
quelques-uns c'est aussi le bruit des
voitures qui passent mais on a trois qui
ont marqué son attention
rien d'alarmant le deuxième
aucun petits bruits électriques ça peut
arriver aussi bon avec toute
l'électronique on a chez nous c'est
totalement envisageable et un autre boom
rien de ouf je vous invite à ne pas
télécharger l'application puisque vous
allez devenir parano il ya vraiment
beaucoup de bruit la nuit surtout si
vous avez des animaux chez vous faut pas
être parano c'est normal moi des fois
mais qu'à des trucs qui tombe ça fait
flat du bruit c'est toujours soin natsu
soit meeschart ce qui est dur dans cette
situation c'est de ne pas devenir parano
ce très important adam part en week-end
pour se vider un peu la tête loin de
david il a bien raison il achète là bas
un polaroïd pour prendre une petite
photo souvenir de vacances et en
rentrant il décide de faire un tour de
son appartement avec cet appareil il
nous montre les photos il dit voilà ma
porte d'entrée mont joli mur jaune de
l'autre côté mon lit avec la fameuse
chaise verte j'aime bien david puis
décide du rsa pendant très prendre une
photo et la photo apparaît complètement
noir adam peut-être fallait-il allumer
la lumière ça ne prend pas de photo dans
le noir de votre iphone et puis là les
trucs étranges s'enchaînent le fameux
sont électriques on écoutait tout à
l'heure il apparaît toutes les nuits
autour de trois heures sauf qu'au lieu
duré vingt secondes il dure 5 minutes
maintenant chaque fois un matin il se
réveille avec l'impression que tout son
appartement tremble comme un petit
tremblement de terre bref la dame et
commence vraiment à être mal tout le
monde lui dit mec quitte l'endroit
arrête tout raté conneries sauf cas
d'amis se dit bah ouais mais le truc va
peut-être me suivre ça sert à rien adam
new deal 22 août que le vendredi soir il
s'endormit très très tôt il était très
crever sans aucune raison apparente il a
alors rêver de david qu'il le prenait
par le bras et l'emmener dans un vieil
entrepôt abandonné au réveil comprenais
pas trop pourquoi il avait pas eu peur
de david et pourquoi david avait réussi
à l'emmener là bas alors que ça fait des
jours qu'adam il a peur de lui mais si
bon ça reste un rêve tout et possédant
un rêve on s'en fout et elle arrive à se
doucher et qu'est ce qu'ils voient sur
son bras y voit une trace rouge et ça
cette mécanique là elle est utilisée
dans beaucoup de films d'horreur tu
rêves d'un truc un contact physique dans
le rêve et au réveil il ya une trace de
ce contact physique kit indique que ya
donc vraiment eu un truc dans le monde
réel adam pars bientôt en vacances au
japon il décide alors d'acheter une
caméra à maître chez lui pour qu'il
puisse choquer à distance si se passe
des trucs bizarres
il ya une application qui relie à cette
caméra et ça lui enverra une
notification s'il ya du mouvement ou du
bruit chez lui elle soit des
notifications lui disant qu'il ya du
mouvement des quais regarde ses chats
qui passe devant
c'est l'horreur c'est caméra l'achetez
pas quoi autour jamais le savoir quoi
mais un moment ses chats ne passe pas
devant alors ils regardent la vidéo il a
regarde et regardez bien la chaise
bush plus tard pareils à ceux
notification de sa caméra c'est une
vidéo de ses chats il la regarde quand
même et il voit son chat sauter sur un
truc invisible alors autant les autres
trucs tu fais web autant la mecque
vraiment les chats y voit des choses
quoi je te jure y voit des choses leur
cerveau leur envoie un signal qui né
d'un tout qui n'existe pas en disant on
regarde y'a un truc là alors car aimait
la vie
d'après philippe porte puisque c'est son
[ __ ] de chat debout sur son canapé qui
regardent en vivent mec là j'avoue c'est
un peu rare il rentre chez lui retrouve
ses chats et là ça part en couille sa
mère il entend du bruit venir de l'autre
côté de sa [ __ ] de porte
il reprend une photo dans le hier et
cette fois ils voient ça qu'ils pensent
être une oreille avec juste à côté un
oeil un peu comme sa mère il se passe
pas mal de trucs et là à damour rêve de
david et ce exactement comme la première
fois où il arrivait du il est assis dans
cette chaise en face de lui le fixie
c'est que ça rêve mais décide de prendre
son téléphone qui est en lien avec lui
et prendre des photos il a fait ça
puisque dans la panique qui s'est dit ça
y est david evans but et je veux qu'ils
aient des preuves dans mon téléphone que
les gens sachent qui m'arrive est cette
fois david lantin il met son visage
juste au dessus du sien ses yeux
deviennent blancs et et un trucs
incompréhensibles puis il les deux bouts
sur le lead and zinc et adobe se
réveille dans la panique sa mère il ya
aucune trace de david adams ses
meilleurs voeux au travail et un moment
il se souvient du rêve il se souvient
qu'il a pris des photos cette fois dans
le rêve et décide d'aller voir dans la
pellicule de son téléphone est là
code il existe les amis c'est la fin de
l'histoire de madame et de dire d'avis
on sait toujours pas si c'est vrai ou si
c'est faux mais on pense que c'est une
histoire créée de toutes pièces
et c'est pas plus mal parce que
franchement l'histoire alléchant mais
pour une fois on n'a pas envie de le
[ __ ] le mec parce que la faim fait au
contraire je ne me permets que c'est
trop bien peu importe que ce soit fait
cobra hausse et qu'il est illustrateur
et cartooniste donc il sait créer des
histoires il a l'habitude de ça il
s'agit là d'un bon gros coup de com pour
lui en tout cas ça a marché sa ferveur
totale et je trouve que c'est tellement
bien géré en plus comme moi là je vous
fais le débrief après coup mais quand tu
suit l'histoire en direct c'est
fantastique mais voilà j'ai juste envie
de raconter cette petite histoire ne
s'est pas aimé la vidéo sur vous ça vous
a plu et peut-être que s'il ya d'autres
histoires comme ça un jour qui voit le
jour décrit pippa stade ce jour là sur
le net
et bien je vous ferai une vidéo mais en
direct pendant que ça se passe j'espère
que vous allez passer une très bonne
nuit et souvenez de mater cette vidéo
avant de dormir
bonne chance pousser tout chaises se
trouvait au bout de votre livre allait
la foudre dans la chambre de votre
petite soeur ou un petit frère je vous
dis à bientôt mère savoir garder mes
gros bisous
[Musique]